1, 2, 3, 4...
Thank you for watching!
Please subscribe to my channel!
I wasn't thinking much during my performance.
You can probably say that you're not thinking about every move.
Like every move that you're not thinking about anything.
You're not thinking about anything.
Per move.
So I keep saying it?
Keep saying it, yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I just keep repeating it.
I wasn't thinking much.
We remove the screen with the help of a pick.
As you can see, your pattern is scored based on the number 10.
So out of 10 is your mark.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation of the site.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from a 4.
So from the number 4...